[musique]
deuxièmement, j'aime beaucoup la gymnastique et bien que je
Puis-je me dire pourquoi pourquoi pas
s'entraîner ou ne pas performer pendant que vous
peux-tu juste si j'ai fini alors je
je sais que je le regrette beaucoup
la moitié de moi n'était pas prête à
allez à ces jeux olympiques et maintenant
je me prépare à préparer
Jeux olympiques
il n'y a qu'un but et un rêve et que je
Je m'efforce et je veux tout avoir
arrivé
[musique]
une athlète d'un si haut niveau qu'elle
se sent juste sur lui-même dans votre corps dans
ton corps tes sentiments
comment où et quel est le meilleur et nous ne pouvons que
aidez-la à garder ce niveau
[musique]
laisser
réépingler
[musique]
Et